1968 war ich angehörige der zweiten
kompanie des jägerbataillons 17 in bad
radkersburg mein dienst greift bester
meine funktion war kommandant einer
bandscheibe gruppe zu diesem zeitpunkt
vom zwanzigster august bis september
weil ich gleichzeitig ausbildungsleiter
der ausbildung von katar personal und
rekruten am schweren panzer bereits 66
in der nacht vom 20 auf den 21 august
wurden wir übungs weise alarmiert stand
in keinem zusammenhang mit der dann
folgenden checken krise und wir bezogen
traditionsnamen verfügung haben dort
selbst bekam ich so gegen drei uhr in
der früh der auftrag mich beim kassieren
kommandanten am thalerhof graz graz ost
zu melden
das tat ich vor mit zwei chelsea und mit
meinen männern nach graz und meldete
mich dort beim kasseler kombattanten er
meinte warten es kommen noch befehle ich
ließ absitzen und wir warteten am frühen
morgen kam der brigadekommandeur regale
kommandant der damalige boskovic und
halte mich wo denn die restliche
computer erwischt weiß ich nicht so viel
ich weiß noch in radkersburg ein
verfügungsrahmen etwa zwei stunden
später aber auch die kompanie dann
geschlossen im thalhof ost und dort
erfuhr ich dann erstmals vom einmarsch
der sowjets in der tschechoslowakei und
von der möglichkeit dass
handstreichartig der flugplatz in graz
thalerhof auch in besitz genommen wird
im zusammenhang mit einer möglichen
lageentwicklung in richtung roßlau
werden
ich sah dann auch unter gezogen 3 1 47
und ein panzerkommandant erzählte mir
dass er bei den auftrag hätte bei anfang
an fliegenden flugzeugen sich quer über
die rollbahn zu bewegen und die
flugzeuge
an der land ring landung zu hindern wir
erkunden einstellungen wie wir unsere
leute einsetzen also diego züge und die
panzer waffen haben aber diese
stellungen nie besetzt haben nur
erkundet
nach einem etwa 50 60 stündigen
aufenthalt in graz thalerhof bekamen
wird dem befehl wieder eindrücken nach
bad radkersburg in bad radkersburg
angekommen wurden wir umfassend
informiert über die vorkommnisse in der
tschechoslowakei und über die
möglichkeit dass es auch im steirischen
grenzraum zu aktionen im zusammenhang
mit einem möglichen einmarsch in oder
gegen jugoslawien kommen könnte dazu
wurde befohlen dass unsere kaserne auch
die grasseler straße in fehring oder in
fellbach zu rundum verteidigung
einzurichten sei das haben wir getan und
haben auf der kaserne eine kleine
festung gemacht dieser zustand dauerte
bis ungefähr 10 september 15 september
und danach hatten wir süd bereitschaft
jeden mittwoch auf donnerstag und jeden
samstag sonntag ab oktober wechseln wir
verbände uns gegenseitig ab einmal der
schwesterpartei wir aber wir sind noch
ungefähr sechs bis sieben mal über das
wochenende in bereitschaft gesessen
während dieser gesamten zeit war immer
scharfe munition auf den lkw s verfügbar
die vorschläge wurden nicht geöffnet
dass es heute keine munition an die
männer ausgegeben
aber es war immer wir waren immer bereit
für einen möglichen einsatz
zufällige fund auch das unter umständen
wir auf folgeschäden gewesen werden
neben der ersten jägerbrigade im
weinviertel eingesetzt zu werden was
dann aber real war konnte ich als
wachtmeister nicht unbedingt bewahrt
werden